let's talk about the big political news
that in my opinion
let me just let me just we'll start over
here it is fox news politico
confirmation of hunter biden laptop
materials prompts criticism of earlier
suppression of story twitter blocked
sharing of new york post story on laptop
last year so the new york post told the
truth hunter biden is he's a crackhead
correct he's a crackhead there's there's
photos and videos of him with like
women of the night still repute yes
no i don't know i don't know if ill
repute is is is fair and acceptable to
our libertarian audience who think you
know sex work is acceptable oldest
occupation there you go that's why i say
women of the night that's not offensive
is it ladies and gentlemen negative i'm
i'm trying to be libertarian although
you know personally not a fan but
you got to be careful because
i don't know that one's actually tough
we should have a conversation about that
maybe when we're not doing family we
could even have a prostitute on some day
to give their personal experience of the
night a woman of the night so anyway
look hunter biden is is is a mess
but i don't i don't care you know what i
mean like it's sure he's a guy he does a
thing a lot of people have problems i'm
not here to revel in a man's problems
the problem i have is it's not criticism
of an earlier suppression of the story
it's criticism of
a democrat democratic operatives working
in media
working at big tech suppressing news
that would have substantia would have
hurt joe biden in the election to a
great degree not because hunter biden
does drugs but because the emails showed
that they were holding 10 that 10 will
be held by h for the big guy that there
were nefarious deals going on and we
don't want a president going into office
who has nefarious deals now back when
trump was running they're like donald
trump has a secret server communicating
with russia lies
so when their criticism was we don't
want a president entering office who has
these ties to foreign interests and is
beholden to them in these debts i'm like
all right you know i can accept that to
a certain degree now it's one thing if
you're a businessman like trump and you
have buildings with mortgages all over
the world
that's like saying we don't want someone
who runs international business to be
president for the sake that they just
because they run international business
now to that extent i will say
true
in some degree for joe biden but when
joe biden flies to ukraine and says
fire the prosecutor
that or you're not getting your billion
dollar in loans joe biden has no right
to leverage the united states providing
aid to ukraine in a conflict with russia
or or potentially there's a con this
conflict between russia and ukraine
threatening them you know we're going to
pull out unless you fire this prosecutor
and as matt taibbi reported the
prosecutor was investigating brismo
where his son was on the board that is
dramatically different from trump having
debt in buildings
so this story gets suppressed what do we
get
i think you know you look at the rest
museum study wrestling did a study found
i think it was like what seven to ten
percent of people yeah nine percent nine
percent when asked if you knew about the
hunter biden stuff would you have voted
for body no
so that would have been dramatically
different now here we are what's been
happening economy inflation's through
the roof border crisis afghanistan
crisis domestic agenda's failing dem the
squad members are i mean i'm already at
five squad members are ripping the
democratic party to shreds which they've
been doing for some time but now they're
pulling funding for the iron dome
wow is the bite administration
completely
unfit now here's my favorite part there
was a poll back in august
most americans think joe biden is unfit
to be president do you know what the
poll today is most uh the uh 48 so it's
not the majority because it's 48 think
he's not even mentally stable well
this is where we are
when the meat when the media manipulates
and lies on news we knew to be true that
we had already confirmed i was
independently confirmed by people
looking at the emails corroborating it
and they suppress this
this is why you end up with a cult that
believes insane things like the economy
is good and regular people of different
political persuasions like everyone here
probably has you know different
political world views but we can
recognize the truth when we see it
i think what annoys me the most about
this story is the media always is is
pulling their weight in a certain favor
right i mean we have innumerable
examples of that in the trump
administration and going back to as long
as i've been following politics what
bothers me the most about this
particular episode is i cannot find uh
i could be wrong but i can't find in my
my memory hole
one other time that twitter actually
suspended technologically the ability to
share the story they have labeled things
as inaccurate facebook of always puts
their stamps on it but the fact that if
you wanted to retweet the story you were
not allowed to
is a whole new level of crackdown that
we never saw before but you couldn't
even send it in a private message right
yes didn't they crack down on that too i
mean that's good privately so that is
unbelievable they suspended one of the
oldest newspapers in this country
alexander hamilton 1799. and we all knew
very early on the story was true because
of independent corroboration statements
from people like tony bobulinsk you came
out and said yes i'm on those email
chains yes those emails are real and
we're like okay so i'm looking at this
like it's not news we knew it was real
what's the revelation but
they suspended a newspaper and the crazy
thing is
it's taken
it's how many months it's been almost a
year
and now they're like oh new york post
was telling the truth the whole time and
that's where you have to go to twitter
the ceo and and they bring him before
congress all the time and they never ask
him hard questions they never really ask
the questions they should but the
question should be here are an example
of 10 other stories that you could
consider as
inflammatory as shocking as
controversial you never suspect that
were also false you never suspended any
of them so twitter walk me through i get
it private platform they can do whatever
they want is the argument walk me
through the criteria that for this story
someone made the decision to say this is
why we have to suspend it as opposed to
and you've dealt with this in your own
personal life one person says all these
things they're totally fine you say this
and it's like oh suspended well what was
the criteria and it seems to be well i
just don't like that person it feels
kind of like being in a band that was a
one-hit wonder and being like you know i
had this big song back in the 80s
because because a few years ago i went
to the joe rogan podcast and i was
talking to jack dorsey and it's like one
one people bring this up all the time so
that's the you know kind of the point
i'm making but i showed them a tweet
from antifa where they were like
everyone go to this place at this time
to commit violence and i was like how
has this tweet been up for months and
the replies to it are getting banned so
clearly someone at twitter sees this
bans replies but lets that one stay i'm
like are you guys feds because the only
reason i can understand that you would
keep that up is it's bait yeah from the
feds makes sense and they're like we we
didn't know about it oh oh geez oh no
i'm like nah okay look
i'm i'm i'm done playing these games
some trump supporter guy says hashtag
learn to code it was you know what it
was it was the editor-in-chief of the
daily caller i think yeah jeffrey
ingersoll
was it he didn't tweet anybody he
tweeted the hashtag he tweeted about
learn to code and they suspended him
that that that i got my details right
absolutely yeah i remember that was
hysterical but you can say it about coal
miners that's what i
jumped on that because
that's the response that that they say
all the time about people in the energy
industry oh you got to learn to code
like that it has been used as a learner
skill that you need in the 21st century
but you can't say that to what was what
was it
um right it was about was it when gawker
was fired or was one of those but it was
one of those it was one of those
publications that went down and that's
what that was pretty funny
i hear you on the congress stuff but i
really don't think there's anything you
can do
bringing these people before congress i
think they are duplicitous i think they
are liars i think they keep calling in
jack dorsey who's a spokesperson
figurehead who doesn't actually do
anything with the company because jack
tweeted he he tweeted the the anatomy of
the state by rothbard and everyone like
was like whoa because he clearly is not
you know it is a weird thing from a
tweet considering he he provides cover
for the machine
but i don't think he's actually running
the show they keep bringing his people
for congress and saying you know you did
this and they're like oh i'll get back
to you i don't know it's nothing happens
nothing nothing changes
i think this country's imploded already
you know i mentioned it the day before
i've mentioned on my other show
and you take a look at the fact that
they've brought how many times have they
been before congress over this stuff
five i don't know
there's no way there's going to be any
meaningful legislation to deal with the
suppression of our speech on these
platforms and the left like say but my
private platform and i'm like it's it's
it's a it's an inane argument okay they
have conquered the commons plus we're
locked down in a lot of places people
can't go out so this is how we're
communicating
at a certain point when they control too
much we have anti-trust laws we or we
come in and we regulate we do these
things we always do it we normally do it
because we don't want companies usurping
the power of the citizenry and the
people and suppressing the rights of the
working class
none of that's gonna happen because
there's no way the republicans and
democrats will agree
even when we had republicans in 2016-18
they were too stupid to realize what was
happening and now they're all getting
banned and they're all but those were
mostly like neocons you know paul ryan
stuff like that
now what we're seeing is while the
republicans can't get anything done
democrats are just cheating they're
trying to put immigration reform in a
spending bill
joe biden is just ruling by decrees
rubber stamping legislation as executive
order and then it just it just happens
so i i all i see is
i was i was reading about um
decline of civilizations before
and there's a period at which
it's been a while back in the specifics
where like you'll start to see
autocratic rule because
it becomes so dysfunctional that the
only way to actually move forward is for
a sovereign to decree and say we have to
do this now otherwise we're doing
nothing so they force things to happen
and that just exacerbates the
stabilization
there are two components of this story
there's the
censorship which is extremely
frustrating says you know suppression of
free speech
what it did to the election etc but then
there's the actual
story itself which is how corrupt is
this family i mean
obviously they've got an awful lot of of
skeletons in their closet and when
you've got a sitting vice president who
negotiated uh trade deals and planned
for his future and every president and
vice president plans for their future
right i mean they all know it's not
going to last forever but he was using
clearly the power of government to build
himself a a very profitable very
lucrative heck you saw it in his tax
returns right his last year as vice
president his net wealth was 400 and
some thousand dollars that year and then
the year after it was 17 point something
million and you're like wow that's a
really great profit margin good year for
him a very good year and so but there's
that level of corruption that you say
well what were the trade deals that you
were negotiating and again the 10 for
the big guy
and they seem to be with pretty awful
people right there it's with china it's
with ukraine it's with and and you know
i hate to rag on hunter biden um well
actually i don't because he's he's a
deplorable
vile human being when your brother dies
of cancer and within the year you are
sleeping with his wife you're leaving
your own wife and your children to sleep
with your dead brother's wife and then
while you're sleeping with your former
sister-in-law making your
cousins now step children you're
sleeping with her sister simultaneously
and in top of the sister you impregnate
a stripper in alabama
you are just you are a scumbag i'm sorry
there's no other way around that like
like and and i'm sorry joe biden must
hate that he looks at hunter because it
reminds him the good son died and that's
gotta eat at him because you are truly a
vile vile human being well to do that to
your kids i imagine his poor kids and
they show the kids all the time the
grandkids joe biden's grandkids my dad
was dead and this dirtbag is sleeping
with my what a disgusting family they're
like the kennedys without the money or
the class wow well i do want well two
things first of all you did get me a
little worked up talking about uh the
little details of his love life that was
yeah it was pretty steamy uh second of
all i would like to defend him because
this man is an artist
okay this man is an artist and where
would we be if it weren't for vile
deplorable human beings who create
quality art i mean he's stretching 75k
yeah yeah so he's an artist that's what
happens that's what artists do they live
they live
is why i wild libertine
love chris and they come fully they cut
deals with china and they kick back you
know 10 to the big guy while he's in
office and uh and no one has to know who
bought the art yes it's
totally cool sounds like money laundry a
little bit yeah
let me let me look i love pulling up the
story because it's important for for
anybody who's like how do i tell my
friends and family about this stuff i
think there's a lot of people who are in
the cult who are who are
i don't want to say too far gone but
very difficult to reach and it's and
it's hard to get to them but at the very
least you can show them an article this
from politico
biden inc that big right of center
publication politico right that huge
over his decades in office middle class
joe's family fortunes have closely
tracked his political career from august
of 2019 and i think they actually have
uh they have like a graphic look at this
they show when joe biden enters the
senate and then james biden
operates seasons change nightclub with
help from unusually generous bank loans
unusually in 87 he launched his first
presidential campaign in his me so about
eight years later his brother uh
james and sarah biden's lion hall group
hired to push washington agenda of
tobacco trial lawyers from mississippi
so the the most important one in my
opinion is let me let me try and find i
think it's 2011.
let me see if i can um
okay here we go
in
where's joe biden joe biden sworn in as
vip 209 paradigms connections to ponzi
scheme or alan stanford and the
fraudulent ponta negra fund come to
light james biden under binding begin to
unwind to unwind paradigm
james biden joins hillstone
international in june of 2011 hillstone
international lands a 1.5 billion
contract to build housing in iraq so joe
biden becomes vice president joe biden
is put in charge of the iraq operation
his brother gets contracts for building
in iraq you know you look at this map
put together by politico tracking his
family's fortunes around him
and
it's just come on it's just so obvious i
mean if the government if not the
government if cnn was able to track down
through facebook that that
old woman who shared a meme about
president trump and knocked on her door
to ask her about it you're going to tell
me the government can put in some system
to say if chris becomes president
chris's sister can't get a 1.5 billion
contract like all these things were just
like oh my gosh we had there was no
safeguards for any of this i mean it's
just it's mind-boggling the level of
grift and corruption and scumbaggery
it's just
it breaks your heart because it makes
you think there's no one left but but
the to the if you were to argue the side
of the people on the other side of the
aisle the people that are really hard to
reach they're just going to say oh
that's politics that's politics yeah
that's just how it goes what's the big
deal so joe made some money i mean
that's just that's how the system works
they all do it yeah they all do it
they'll do it
yeah
some stories about trump that are not
the same as i mentioned or or fake
and this this story from joe biden from
2019 it's not like he was running for
office and there was a smear piece
against him now i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna pretend trump's a saint but
there's a big difference between being
some crazy real estate mogul who's got a
bunch of buildings around the world and
you have debts on them like i think it's
funny when the story came out where
they're like trump was 500 million in
debt on his properties and people were
like whoa and i'm like yeah okay
those are his liabilities what are his
assets
and then trump came out and he was like
yes i have mortgages on buildings like
everybody else and the buildings are
worth a billion um
it just lies
manipulation yeah and and i just the
biden
the unraveling of their level of
corruption i think
deserved to come to a head before the
election it clearly did not um but this
is this is standard behavior for the
media where they either exacerbate
stories that they think are are
interesting or fascinating or a
narrative you could look to we're going
to talk about miss potito later on right
there's a narrative they like to push of
missing women there's a narrative about
racism they like to push but then you
have another story you know case in
point there was a terrible school
shooting three or four days ago and i
forget where it was
news no coverage because people looked
at the narrative and they were like eh
it doesn't help the cause nothing i
would like to say that we did cover that
at tim castner it's good
we did you should have because it is
newsworthy but this is where you know i
think what bothers me about the media or
um
just just their their level of
disgusting behavior because they push
their narrative is
one of the very first things that
happened when trump was sworn into
office um
and i've followed media bias for a while
but this one i thought set the tone for
his administration uh january 20th 2017
it was 5 30 in the afternoon hours after
and it was uh zeke miller on behalf of
the white house press pool who tweeted
uh president trump has removed the
martin luther king bus from the oval
office that's right and sean spicer saw
the tweet in real time and was like dude
it's right there
but it didn't matter the damage was done
and he could have as a good member of
the press said hey sean i gotta ask
before i tweet this did you remove the
mlk bust and spicer would have said no
it's right there but he didn't verify
because he won the damn narrative and
that's what they do
all the time and you just have to see
that those things explode 500 000
retweets 1 million likes but then the
retraction you know it's not journalism
it's gossip it is it is that's it like
started
itself a new version has re-emerged is
it still called gawker yes it is oh gosh
but it really started with yellow
journalism like there's been a long
tried history of like really i mean just
biased reporting yeah so it's been
around for a long time and it's just
gotten worse yeah so there's money to be
made you know the crazy thing is we can
see it now and we're shocked by it but
imagine the stories you would have read
in the paper in the 90s the 80s 90s
2000s before we had a strong internet
culture where that was challenging and
fact checking them people just believed
it look at mbmcs man yeah look at the
nbc news uh during the the the trayvon
martin case right when they edited the
audio uh of of um
zimmerman and it was like and he said he
looks like blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah black and they just clipped it
he looks like he's black and they were
like wow he said something like he said
that he looks like he's up to no good he
looks black yeah and then it turns out
he said he looks like he's up to no good
and then he says is he white is he
mexican or black and he goes he's black
yeah
yeah
yeah
they just took all that out do you
remember
on september 11th when they said they
found one of the guys passports one of
the hijackers passports on the ground
outside the wreckage oh yeah like it
fell out of the airplane and landed on
the ground i don't remember that
you don't have a media that's insane
holy cow the one thing that survived
amongst the rubble is his past yeah
they're like we know who's laid on top
well that's that's the official story
yeah isn't that what the heck like a
passport fell out of an airplane what
are they talking about
you know
jet fuel doesn't melt
passports apparently
i don't i don't know why ian went there
with the story
free internet news it's like that was
like the end of the pre-internet news
era and then the weapons of mass
destructions thing and
now we kind of have an ability to
fact-check stuff on our own but before
like the first war in iraq i wonder how
much was going on there that we don't i
got it i got it thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you